قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اف جالنت ان
نشاط القوات الاسرائيليه في خانيونس كبير
وانه سوف يتصاعد قريبا اضاف جالنت عقب
جوله جويه في سماء قطاع غزه ان الدخان سوف
يبقى يلف قطاع غزه حتى تحقق اسرائيل ما
وصفها باهداف حربه بتقويض حركه حماس
واستعاده الرهائن
لقد نزلت للتو من جوله جويه مع السرب 100
فوق قطاع غزه رايت القوات العامله في شمال
القطاع ووسطه وجنوبه الامور تبدو وكانها
غير عاديه لقد شهدت هجوما مباشرا من قبل
سلاح الجو في جنوب مدينه غزه ان الدقه
وجوده التنفيذ والتنسيق المثاليه مع
القوات مثيره للاعجاب للغايه نحن نعمل
بنشاط كبير في منطقه خان يونس وسوف نستمر
في تصعيد نشاط
سيستمر دخان الدبابات والمدافع وطائرات
سلاح الجو يتصاعد في سماء غزه حتى نحقق
اهدافنا وفي مقدمها تقويض حماس وعوده
المختطفين الى وطنهم